it's a it's a long process and I think a
lot of I mean what's been wonderful and
you know the United States has led on
this is is the is the money for anti
retrovirals and that's been really
really important particularly because
it's kept alive people the parents and
the people who are needed now to bring
up the next generation and also the the
the professional middle class which is
so vitally needed in Africa there's not
nobody as far as I can see has
completely convincingly cracked the
prevention problem you can see the the
figures go down and you wonder why and
you look at it and you think yeah maybe
the the canvas big publicity campaign or
something like that but then they start
to creep up again inexplicably so
they've leveled off in many places but
that may be for a whole lot of factors
and nobody has yet come up with a way of
convincing a large number of Africans to
take prevention seriously and I think
that is the that's the that's the big
that's the big one because it's really
only oh I say only but it's a huge
problem in southern Africa I mean
Swaziland is is for example is a
catastrophe nearly 40 percent infection
rate it's just it's just horrific but
the East Africa it's becomes it's
stabilized West Africa it hasn't
happened as people predicted and we're
not quite sure why maybe it's levels of
circumcision which seems to help prevent
the disease spreading and it may be
Islam as well at that those society is
not are not promiscuous but to stop the
spreading elsewhere nobody's cracked at
yet
of the things that strikes you in Africa
is is this is a very spiritual view of
the world which in one some ways are
wonderful because it is we've we've lost
it we're very mechanical in the way we
deal with things but it has its
downsides and one of it is that when
something happens when something happens
to you or you don't you you you don't
say oh that was a bad accident that was
bad luck you say you know who has made
this happen to me and there's a an
element of that use of spiritual power
so your feeling is an enemy has got
someone who has powerful as you know
it's got a spirit to come and make you
have that accident nothing happens by
accident in Africa there's always
somebody behind it and then who has
manipulated the spirits in some way to
make it happen and I wonder whether you
know that if you apply that to to sex
and AIDS and so on they may mean two
things may happen that carrying on the
the having children spreading humanity
spreading life is a very powerful
instinct there on the other hand if I
something bad happens to me it's not my
fault someone has done this to me so
there's a lack of of agency of personal
agency in your life and I think that
that maybe have to be broken down
if aids is to stop spreading
you